and finally new rule both candidates
must sign a pledge that whoever loses
the election in November whether it's
Hillary or whether it's orange Hitler
actually at fair and balanced the loser
has to congratulate the winner and
concede graciously why because civility
is nearly dead in this country and we
need to return to some basic level of
bipartisan decency and respect for our
opponents otherwise we're going to wind
up being governed by those
good-for-nothing [ __ ] on the other
side you see this log is one person all
right now you may not think that
something as simple as congratulating
your opponent should rise to the level
of a campaign issue but if you want to
know why our country is so tense and our
government doesn't work it's because
society functions on some basic rules of
conduct and they're all going away it's
why filibustering has become not a rare
principled protest but the everyday
automatic cock-blocking that defines
government now Ted Cruz filibustered
Obamacare for nearly a day by reading
green eggs and ham a book about how you
might like something if you give it a
chance
it's why Republicans who claim to
worship the Constitution can now just
ignore their duty in filling a Supreme
Court vacancy and speaking of the
Supreme Court which used to stay
supremely out of partisan bickering it's
why Ruth Bader Ginsburg yes even sweet
scholarly grandmotherly Ruth Bader
Ginsburg talked trash about Trump this
year like she was in a rap battle oh
that man can bring out the worst in
anyone but I have to tell you Donald
Trump didn't create this swamp he just
rose from it he and Hillary he and
Hillary are the first two candidates in
memory not to call and congratulate each
other after they won their respective
races forever that is what people did
even Al Gore called george w bush after
he lost and he didn't even lose
[Applause]
in the Senate members used to refer to
each other as my friend from the other
side of the aisle they didn't mean it
literally of course no one actually
thinks of Ted Cruz as a friend but you
say it anyway
it's like in a marriage occasionally to
keep things functional you have to tell
little lies like you're more handsome
bald or I'm dying to hear about your day
or I love it that you only blow me on my
birthday it makes it special
[Applause]
but in politics we've forgotten how to
do that why not blow each other we feel
not anything did it break down when we
decided it was okay to say that the
president was a Kenyan spy baby yeah it
didn't help
neither did when someone shouted out you
lie at the State of the Union and it's
only gotten worse a Republican senator
this year called Obama a drug dealer the
governor of Maine left a voice message
for one of his political opponents
calling him a socialist [ __ ] even
within the party they do it Alan Grayson
lost a Democratic primary in Florida
last month refused to endorse the guy
who beat him and then called him a
Republican now come on call a guy a
traitor or a [ __ ]
I keep saying that this election is a
referendum on decency it's a chance to
reject the gutter and punish people who
want to live there but right now we are
rewarding them the guy you said you lie
the next day donations poured into his
coffers because now in America when you
act like an [ __ ] you're a hero
this is what Parliament looks like on a
bad day in the Ukraine and here's the
Turkish Parliament and the one in South
Korea and the one in Nepal yeah we laugh
at it but that is where we're headed
because the real infectious disease
that's threatening our election isn't
pneumonia it's a total lack of class
this is supposed to be a democracy not a
bum fight
let's leave the eye-gouging to the
pageant moms and the hair-pulling to the
Italians just a little decency for old
times sake so the neighbors don't think
we're trash because we haven't built
that wall yet and the Mexicans can hear
everything